I think what we have here in Hollywood
is high Arts it's
[Applause]
[Music]
party
anyway
world where would you go
I always wanted to be part of something
bigger yes let's go
[Music]
so I'm actually going to start with
asking you guys about something that no
one's probably asked you about yet
that opening party scene man
opening partition that goes on for 30
minutes florals and spring
groundbreaking it's all I'm talking
about it's so gnarly and gargantuan that
I I had to start off by asking you guys
what is one detail from shooting that
sequence that you feel like you'll
remember forever
[Laughter]
the like actual emojis that were
literally happening
um
this is a load of nudity yeah there was
a lot of nudity a lot of nudity as Gene
says you she tells it better but yeah be
careful where you get backed up yeah
right
for a while and and to keep the energy
up every time it was so kind of
hilarious we would all band together and
we had the most incredible group of
background artists you know composed you
know Dances I think some people are
actual porn stars just extras friends
you know everyone kind of in there
together and creating this atmosphere
day after day after day hour after hour
and it was just we'd all kind of pump
each other up like a sport team going on
to the field it'd be like all right come
on come on and then we'd go for another
take and then yeah three two one nudity
yeah literally Damien chazelle is able
to cram so much in yeah one shot yes
incredible yeah I've never quite seen it
really and the camera is like
capturing it on he's just waiting for
you know to tell it that one take where
everything falls into place it's wild
pretty magical I can't wait for the
world to see it it was my favorite scene
in the movie but another scene that I
really loved
love and Jack and it reminded me about
the last thing you and I talked about
after I talked to you after bullet train
because we were talking about the later
stage in your career and I was watching
it and I was wondering I wonder what
further Reflections Brad is having on
his own career after shooting this scene
I've never thought that we were
more important than the machine itself
you know the film takes place when this
new industry is is blooming and uh
they're defining they're defining itself
and making that big jump of course a lot
of the silent artists were left behind
and they moved to more theater actors
for me no I I I've never I've always
seen us as all part of a community and
not that the thing does not exist with
one of us it exists with all of us and
and you see this lineage of all the
people you've come before and I see this
younger Generations coming up and Diego
being one of them and doing fantastic
work and it's all you just feel a part
of this and this wonderful lineage of
community that's that's the way I feel
about it oh that's beautifully said and
I love that you just said that about
Diego Diego you you know man crush it
you did crush it I mean he walked in you
know and crushed he really did and Manny
has such an interesting entrance into
Hollywood and you did too because I was
reading that Damien had you pretend to
be a production assistant on a
commercial that he was shooting with
Brad is that how you guys first met can
we hear more about that day yeah Damian
called me and he told I was in Mexico
and he told me like I want to direct
this commercial and Brad is a lead but
also you are going to get to know like
the DP the custom designer blah blah
blah but the idea like in the cruel is
in the crew member of the commercial I
was Damian's assistant and then the man
told me like work as a Pao so the idea
is like nobody has to know that you are
the actor so I was working there like a
PA giving coca-colas and bringing coffee
to everyone and at some moment it was
Mary Mary the custom designer we were
sitting in a in a couch and uh Mary told
you like Brock have you met Diego
and it was like a little confusing and
Damian was like I wanted to be a secret
but is that Damien chasselle's mind like
meta fictional sometimes but also like
very creative you know like this is an
opportunity let's do it let's pretend
you're a PA why not it's a great way to
meet that why not
did that throw you first
wait that wait what oh great that's so
funny Margo I have had I've been so
lucky and had the pleasure of being able
to interview you in so many different
roles and I read that you said this is
probably the greatest role you'll ever
play and when I saw you fight that snake
I was like she's not wrong what would
you like choreographing that scene and
what was it like for the both of you
watching her do that
no shame wow no machine whatsoever we
were all out in the desert and uh the
freezing desert freezing desert I have
no top on for all the things that were
carefully crafted and choreographed this
one actually kind of wasn't and it was a
lot of me like flapping like trying to
fling my arm around to fling this puppet
snake up so it would look like it was
real and writhing in the air and then
just screaming and running after people
and it was just it was a show like the
way the way it looks on screen is
actually a little bit how it was like I
would run after Lucas and he's got the
toilet seat around his name he TR I mean
it was so it was so hard not to laugh
but we we had a lot of fun and then of
course there's you know Diego's
character goes down and Brad's character
goes down and it's just all hell breaks
loose and then Lily's character comes in
and kind of like bosses the situation
but I mean it was it was insane we had
real rattlesnakes uh that were full of
Venom as well quote unquote the rap
snack Wrangler said huge Rattlers it was
it was just the whole thing was Madness
like an average
by snakes
they're the 10 dead ones
well thanks for sharing that that scene
was just the best I love this movie so
much and when I went home and reflected
back on it I had such an outer body
experience because I live here in LA and
I was like whoa how many people have
like lived in my apartment that like
worked in the movie industry and how
many people are going to be having the
conversations of having with you guys
right now just like hundreds of years
from now the sort of immortal
immortalness of it was so that's why
Damian's so amazing but I think what I
took away the most was this is really a
movie about people who want to make
their Mark in the world and so I wanted
to know what stamp do you want to leave
on this big ocean we call the movie
business that we're just like waves in
well I you know I would say I mean the
characters you see in all in different
ways are all fighting for you know to
have meaning to be loved and some about
a go go about it in healthy ways and
some of us don't but
um it's just that just to be able to
contribute to the you know to this this
you know I mean I think of the stories I
grew up with and how they affected me
they got me out of my hometown and out
to see the world so you know to be a
part of that I you know and hopefully
some some of the stories
that I've been able to be in will do the
same yeah what would you where would you
guys land I think this is
me leaving my mock this that's why I
wanted to tell you this one part of this
yeah that's why I wanted to be a part of
this movie so bad I thought this is
gonna be one that stands the test of
time this is going to be a movie that
people still watch in 10 20 30 plus
years
and I'll be a part of Hollywood history
if I'm in this movie yeah
yeah and that's how people is going to
remember you
as Nelly like she was crazy I don't know
it's a dream and I like the idea of
here Los Angeles not California
Hollywood this is the place where the
dreams come true right and at least for
me it's it's happening so I think that
quote is true
you know when I first moved to L.A
you know what shines on all the doors
read no actors or dogs allowed
I changed that good morning good job for
you I'll do anything
they said to screw us
Gina congratulations on this movie it's
it's so good one of my favorite scenes
is between Eleanor and Jack she's
talking to him about the Twilight of his
career and I was watching it and I was
thinking about how you and Brad are
these veteran actors and I wanted to
know did the both of you reflect on the
meaning of that scene we didn't talk a
lot about it
um because it's just so
gorgeously written you know that it was
just kind of all there on on paper but
and and Brad doesn't have a lot to say
but I mean working with him and it just
the look in his eyes it was just it was
like
a heartbreaking you know because it's
that
what she says to him is what every actor
fears and doesn't want to believe is
true
and it's um kind of devastating
but then she ends up you know just she's
right there telling him
you're you're going to be immortal I
mean
people who aren't even born yet are
going to know who you are and think they
know you and and that is that magic that
everybody kind of is attracted to though
we all are it's like everyone in this
room right like it's it's the immortal
and mortalness of it it just that really
stuck with me when you're like 50 years
from now some kid's gonna see you and
it's inspired I mean like that's so true
for you too Gene and I just love your
character Eleanor because first of all
you have like the best characters with
the most insane fashion sense ah yes
just like the best but I know that
Damien also made you base your character
off various writers from that era right
like Eleanor Glenn and Adela Rogers St
John's I was wondering what you took
from those people to sort of create your
Eleanor
well I mean again I always I don't I try
not to go overboard with research
because I feel like if it doesn't
support the script then it's just going
to be a conflict so I always let the
script sort of be my my road map but he
did he did uh mention
um a couple people to me specifically
Eleanor Eleanor Glenn and I found her
really fascinating because she
she was sort of a fairly proper English
woman but at the same time she wrote
very racy novels and she came to
Hollywood because she obviously was
attracted to this industry and you know
she was one of the very first women to
ever write a screenplay
and she wrote um a movie that clarabo
did and she coined the phrase it girl
wow I didn't know that yeah yeah and uh
she was she was really interesting
that's really fascinating thanks for
sharing that I love the conviction that
Eleanor has and every time I've heard
you speak publicly Gene like whether
you're accepting an award you have this
unalterable knowingness and presence oh
my gosh thank you and it is so I just
had to ask you where do you think that
comes from
well that's a very nice thing to say I I
don't know I I guess um
if you feel strongly about something
then it's really easy to talk about it
it's sort of like when you watch
politicians and you can tell immediately
or at least
you should be able to tell immediately
um some people get fooled
um whether or not they really believe
what they're saying or they feel
passionate about what they're saying
like the way when you listen to you know
Obama's speak you know I mean you could
tell or or Clinton too for that matter
both super bright and you knew that they
could just speak
endlessly on a topic because they felt
strongly about it and they knew a lot
about it and they didn't have to stop
and think or even you know look at notes
or anything it was just kind of but I'm
getting off topic but I um
I guess part of it too is just you know
doing it long enough you sort of feel
more comfortable and
every time I watch you I'm like how can
I get that I love it well you just have
to live a little bit longer a lot longer
that's so funny is it important for you
for a character when you're picking a
role for your character to have that
conviction too because I've noticed it
when I've seen you in Watchmen or hacks
or you know in this
well no not necessarily because I
certainly want to do things that are
kind of very different from each other
um
that's sort of the goal as an actor to
not do the same thing you know so no not
necessarily but maybe I'm attracted to
to Parts like that
um
like
when I think about like say for instance
the character I played in Fargo you know
and people said oh she was scary I
thought no she was just a really
supportive mother
[Laughter]
I'm telling you it's that conviction
it's so magnetizing and absorbing I love
it about you so much I just want you to
know when I watch
um I have to ask you about the most
outrageous party scene like known to man
that's like literally right behind you
what is one detail from shooting that
sequence that you'll just remember
forever
well one thing that just made me laugh
in retrospect and retrospect was
the party scene at Jack's house the pool
party where there's topless women and
guys are jumping in the pool in their
Tuxedos and everything and Eleanor is
just kind of sitting there kind of just
taking it all in I don't think it
actually ended up
as part of the scene I don't think we
actually focused on Eleanor at all in
that scene but when we shot it I didn't
even realize until we were almost done
that the whole time there were four
young guys completely naked behind me
throwing a football back and forth
talk about being upstaged I didn't even
know they were there when did you know
this I well I because because the next
scene is when we're all going to the
desert to watch Margot fight the snake
and there was a little scene which ended
up getting cut
where I'm squished in the back of this
car with all four of those guys and
they're like shirtless and drunk and I'm
just you can tell Eleanor's just kind of
in hog heaven she's like you know have
any of you read any of my books and
she's like oh and of course they're like
clueless you know but wait that's
amazing Damien we need to release that
please that's literally iconic
um before I leave Eugene that's that's
an image I'll never forget I feel like
this movie is really about people just
wanting to leave their mark on the world
so I wanted to know like what stamp do
you want to leave on this industry in
this massive ocean we call the movie
industry that we're all just like waves
in
well I've always tried to
when I was younger I would I would think
okay I don't want to do anything do
anything that'll embarrass my parents
I know that's a silly thing for an actor
to think I got no huge argument with a
friend once who literally stopped
speaking to me because I said that he
said well you're not a real actor you
know if you don't do you know nude
scenes all this kind of stuff
okay whatever but
um
I've always wanted it to be something
that I would be proud of and not be
ashamed of and that it was well written
and and and
um
it was interesting because Charlton
Heston who I would not normally quote
Charlton Heston but he said something
that I thought was very wise one time he
said as an actor
if I believe I have the power to make
people feel something or think
differently about something you know or
Enlighten them about something he said I
also have to accept the fact that I
could affect them negatively
not just positively
I've always thought that was a really
smart observation
and so I try to I try to think about
that I don't want to do anything that's
damaging
well if only that friend you got in a
fight with knew that you were in the
back of a car with four shirtless sweaty
guys
you know we have to do
you have to redefine the form map those
dreams and print them into history look
up and say Eureka I'm not alone
let's talk about the opening party scene
[Laughter]
what detail from shooting that sequence
do you feel like will just remain
ingrained in your brain and for years
and years to come like if you had to
close your eyes and just think of like
the imagery oh gosh should I be a little
bit more
obscure absolutely no
the amount of skin
um a great way to put it yeah man hey
right and the the large volume of white
powder that was
pushed out on a cart that was the first
time on set where I realized oh my gosh
this is how it was back in the day and
how did not more people die every day
it does smell like baby powder I think
it was lactate powder
that's just a funny question
like baby powder it's just that there
was so much of it I love that smell yeah
it was definitely like no it wasn't baby
powder it was lactate powder right what
about you Joan what's the it's the same
as the amount of skin there's just so
much going on and I was like I've never
been so hyper focused on something where
I had the trumpet in my hand and I was
just like close your eyes pretend you're
hitting a really high note because it's
it's so distracting and also because
there were so many moving Parts in that
scene
we really couldn't afford to get
distracted so everybody was doing their
own thing but the cameras forever moving
so if you're you're doing that count and
it's like by count 15 the Duty's
supposed to have the champagne bottle
like you know yeah in his back or
whatever because everything's the dance
you know so well how long did it take
you guys to shoot that game I think we
decided it was two weeks we forgot it
felt like two weeks two weeks feels
right yeah I think it was which feels
like a year when you're doing it like
over and over over and over again high
energy fully committed yeah amazing
background actors who are just like yeah
well let's talk about you guys though
fully committed that performance Lily
was so good thank you it was just you
were so
um mesmerizing thank you and I know that
sometimes actors can come to their
characters more through finding how they
dance so I wanted to know how did that
performance help you find Lady Faye
um well I started out as a dancer and
then I kind of took uh singing lessons
um on this side and then acting came
last so I started out a musical theater
and to have been able to do this film
and get to use all three things that
I've you know learned to do in my life
was really rewarding and it almost felt
like a nice Circle
um but it was it was really fulfilling
because I got to do you know stage
performing again that day because I got
to perform in front of all the
background actors which I had not done
in a long time since I was last time on
stage
so you're like I'm a triple threat yeah
but I was like so nervous because like
don't fall don't trip you know all these
things yeah um Jovan I wanted to ask you
thank you for answering that I was
reading that you and Damian were texting
a lot different songs to each other to
help to sort of craft who Sydney Palmer
is and I was wondering if there was a
song specifically that resonated with
you yes Lush Life by John Coltrane and
Johnny Hartman was one of the most
beautifully written and performed solved
but also one of the most like depressing
and it's not that we felt that like
Sydney was always depressed or anything
like that we just talked about jazz
music and which songs stayed with us the
most like after we listened to them and
that was that's one of my favorite ones
is actually that whole album is called
Lush Life but the the single Lush Life
and Damien's I can't remember what
Damian's was but he also has a way
larger Jazz collection in his uh in his
repertoire than I do so but yeah wow I
love the way that you described that I
feel that way when I listen to
Thelonious Monk there's like it's
Impressions
yeah it's so good and I know that you
guys use Duke Ellington and Curtis Mosby
as references so what did you pull from
them to sort of craft yourself it was
more just a conversation about those
about these early pioneers and along
with them I shared with uh Damien there
was a it's on YouTube now I think but
there was a round table on Charlie Rose
I believe it was and it was with Stanley
approach when Marcellus and Robert
Greene were all different pioneers and
Jazz but more contemporary jazz and they
had this discussion about what music
meant to them and what music or jazz
music specifically how important it was
to like the musical diaspora or whatever
um and I kind of used that conversation
to take
I took like things from each of those
guys as far as like how they spoke you
know their personalities and things and
I kind of took a little bit of from
everybody to kind of build Sydney and
Sydney wasn't solely based on one person
so I had her freedom to kind of take
some creative license and just have some
fun right and that's what's so cool
about all the characters in this film is
there there's little parts of a bunch of
different people like lady Faye for
example of course there's anime Wong but
partially inspired where does where does
uh anime start and stop in your
character and then what did you bring to
ladies day I mean she was presented
initially as anime Wong so a lot of
research was done on her when we uh when
I was casting and said you know this is
a fictional character based on anime but
here are some of the scenes that here
are some of the scenes from films the
great Classics that inspired it such as
um Marlena Dietrich in Morocco is the
inspiration obviously for the opening
number in The Tuxedo so I think it's
just we we still share a very
similar characteristics with a little
bit of both of them it's just sort of
like making a little martini with a
couple of ingredients so yeah it all
came together just through again same
same thing a little lots of chats about
what we like what felt right we tried a
different different a bunch of different
voices and yeah
well you make a stellar lady Faye
Martini shaken not stirred I loved it
what I really took away from watching
this movie like when I went home was
just this notion that it's really just
about people who want to make their mark
on the world and so I wanted to ask
about the view what do you hope your
stamp is on this like huge thing we call
the movie industry like hundreds of
years from now
I think that's it it's just to be spoken
about hundreds of years from now that'd
be great I mean there's so many like
that'd be cool yeah not to say it so
casually but there are so many gifted
artists that exist right now that are
probably like out on the street that
will never get discovered it's just like
a weird thing of life and especially in
this industry so just to be able to make
a mark and to be remembered as an artist
who always tried to push himself and
enjoyed what he what he what he does I
think that's what I would want people to
think of me yeah as an actor who was
given the opportunity to portray someone
who paved the way a century ago you know
and and being able to tell my version of
this story and then
um paying it forward and hopefully you
know the younger generation will get to
see it and it should Inspire them to
also pursue their dreams without any
obstacles like we once had
we are going to be more than they ever
bargained for
what I do means something
it's because of you
[Applause]
I was just in New York and I love La so
I wanted to thank you for making films
about LA because there's so many about
New York and I was reading that
um you shot this in 35 millimeter
anamorphic format because you said that
La is an anamorphic City and I love your
perspective about La so I wanted to know
what kind of character is LA to you who
who is La well la has changed a lot for
me ever since I moved here you know I'm
still kind of figuring out who La is I
think that's part of what's magical
about it is that it is many different
things and and really at its core it's
just this completely unique singular
almost kind of non-city City I think
there's an irrationality to even the
origins of La if you think of sort of
building this town basically in the
desert you know and how rapidly it grew
Beyond anyone's expectations I mean you
sort of see a little bit of that in this
movie La going from you know kind of
rural Cow Town basically to Major World
metropolis and a lot of that have has to
do with the movies of course and this
sort of the the kind of Moths To The
Flame sort of uh atmosphere that the
movies uh spurred on
um but you still feel that in La you
feel the dreamers you feel the people
striving you feel the moth to the flame
you feel also the desperation of that
you feel the good and the bad of it it's
it's a kind of crazed again singular
place
um that has an energy that's really
again unique I think in the world and so
uh yeah for me you know with this movie
at least it was really a matter of
trying to capture that and do that
Justice and sort of maybe see to what
extent you know sort of where that came
from yeah it's interesting that you said
good and bad because when you when I
think of La La Land I think of a film
that's a Hollywood fantasy when I think
Babylon I think of a Hollywood Nightmare
and I was wondering did you did you ever
think of Babylon as a companion film to
La La Land how do you think they
complement each other I do think they
are sort of two sides of of this coin
that is La maybe one is the dream the
other is the nightmare uh I think of La
La Land as this sort of uh you know
Tender Love Letter uh uh of all my sort
of most affectionate feelings about Los
Angeles and this is maybe more of a
poison pen letter but you know at the
same time I kind of wanted to do
everything in this movie I wanted this
movie to sort of Encompass the full the
full meal that is La the good and the
bad there's a lot of love in this movie
and it was a labor of love to make and
and it kind of took many years for it to
just sort of gestate and develop in my
mind uh it was the biggest undertaking
I'd ever done you know so it sort of
took me a while a while to feel like I
was ready to do it
um but I think part of that has to do
with fact that I wanted to try to do
justice to both sides of the spectrum of
La the sort of weird Paradox this
contradiction of Hollywood of the movies
of of Los Angeles that is
um you know on the one hand the highest
you know kind of the uh of humanity the
sort of you know the the most beautiful
people the most beautiful art the kind
of like uh this sort of um you know
Humanity approximating the Divine on the
one hand and then on the other hand just
the most sordid depraved like just kind
of uh sometimes disturbing uh shocking
outrageous kind of behavior that you
could ever imagine and those two things
coexist and they really coexisted In
This Very Vivid way kind of this kind of
Untamed way uh back in the early days
back in the 20s I think Hollywood
learned how to cover a lot of that stuff
up and sweep it under the rug as time
went on but back in the time of this
movie it was all still new and it was
wild and you still felt the circus roots
and you felt this kind of energy in the
air that was was completely insane I
mean first of all I did a writing
Workshop called making peace with
Paradox and I think that you absolutely
nailed the parent because I think that's
life right is making piece of the
Paradox and you enabled it because that
is what La is there's like high highs
and there's low lows and you talked
about it being a labor of love in the
1920s and I know that you you did so
much research you know you watched films
from the era went through historical
archives that all ended up becoming this
100 page single space document called
the dissertation yeah and I was
wondering out of all of that research
you did I didn't call it the district
that's how my producer referred to it
sorry this is a dissertation you're
giving me we started joking about it
like that because it kind of felt like
that it was like 10 years of research
just sort of single space piled into
this document I was like okay we got to
find a story here amazing what was the
craziest thing that you uncovered about
the 1920s and in there's just stuff that
left my jaw on the floor and that was
what I wanted the movie to do to
audiences I had this idea in my head as
I think a lot of people do of the 1920s
as this sort of um you know like the
wildest thing people did was drink a
little too much and dance to Charleston
and maybe wear a bobbed haircut or
something like that was the sort of that
was what was wild back then and it's
just not true you know the the I didn't
realize how much cocaine use there was
at the time how many drugs that now of
course are illegal were legal at the
time how much that sort of drug adult
Behavior informed how they made movies
how they partied how they lived
um people dying young you know suicides
drug overdoses just again these sort of
extremes of behavior people becoming
movie stars like that like overnight
literally overnight uh and uh and then
completely toppling over the next you
know a year later I mean there was just
this sort of
um turbulence to the time that I just
don't think many movies have have done
Justice to yeah and I love that you made
this because anyone going in thinking
like oh my God this is like a lot or
it's excess it's like well that's how it
was exactly and I love
um oh I just love that you did that
obviously no one's ever gonna forget the
Epic opening party scene what what was
it like shooting that and or what was it
like being in that chaos and is there
one specific detail that you feel like
well you'll just never forget
it was sort of like a Vortex it felt
like you know because we had this sort
of incredible set that our uh production
designer reflection Martin That's
rebuilt and we had the whole cast there
it was part of why I wanted to begin the
movie with the parties that it's an
ensemble movie so you have to kind of
have a reason to have your whole your
whole cast of characters in one space
before they go their separate ways so
you've got Brad Pitt you've got Margo
you've got Diego calvo you've got flea
you've got Gene Smart you've got the
whole sort of Jovan Legion Lee got music
blasting so you know we're on set we've
got the full cast we've got like 300 of
the most you know I'd say the most
uninhibited extras I've ever seen uh you
know and uh you know the first few days
it was hard it was challenging the
logistics were really complicated you're
trying to sort of get the steps right
and trying to figure out how to shoot
this but by day three day four it
started to actually feel like a party
you know so I think by the end we felt
like we were kind of emerging from a
two-week Bender of some kind where you
know as far as I know no one was
literally drunk or high though again who
knows but we sort of felt like we were
getting drunk and high on the atmosphere
on the movie and and I think that comes
across in the film total 100 is there
one detail that you
that oh one detail I mean sort of that
remains rent-free in your mind
uh well yeah I mean um
I guess I mean it's sort of central to
the scene but you know I just can't stop
thinking about this dance that Margot
does that um you know that she'd sort of
been rehearsing for a while kind of you
know figuring out sort of uh the broad
Strokes for it just like in a dance
studio and you know we sort of would do
kind of small rehearsals with her and
the choreographer but then once we
actually started shooting it and she's
surrounded by again very uninhibited
extras and dancers in ridiculous
costumes and like floating paper mache
heads and stunts and you know animals I
mean the whole thing having her in the
center of that and what's amazing about
Margot is that you know you can create
the most sort of over-the-top spectacle
of a scene but you put Margot Robbie in
it and you still can only look at her
that's the definition of a movie star
and so it was kind of this amazing
moment in the movie where her character
is literally kind of becoming a star
showing people that she's a star at that
moment
and and I think there's this meta thing
going on where Margot Robbie the actress
is doing exactly the same thing
reminding us what that special something
that's intangible that you can't really
put into words uh is that a star has and
you just can't take your eyes off her
it's one of the most mesmerizing
stretches of sort of performance uh kind
of physical performance that I've ever
seen an actor uh do on film she really
is so absorbing and I was talking to
Gene Smart about you know the
character was very was based on and she
was telling me how one of them had
coined her name's escaping me had coined
the it girl phrase that's Eleanor yeah
yeah and watching Margot the crying
scene I mean that was Unreal it was so
well done I was so obsessed um all the
characters and all the casts are amazing
but there's another character in the
film I wanted to ask you about and that
is Singing in the Rain
um I feel like that film is very much a
character in yours and I wanted to know
why that was instrumental to the story
that you were trying to tell well you
know it's it's the first time I ever
encountered this period this transition
in Hollywood history from Silent Cinema
to sound Cinema was the way it's
depicted it's singing The Ray
um and so I think as I was making this
movie it sort of uh bit by bit dawned on
me then in some ways what we were doing
was making this kind of you know darker
R-rated like more extreme Counterpoint
to sing in the Rain the sort of uh
showing in some ways uh what I think is
sort of closer to the truth of the the
sort of more sordid reality of what was
going on uh that you get a sliver of and
sing in the rain which is has always
been one of my favorite films um so it
kind of felt like we could have this fun
dialogue you know between the two movies
and and and and in this movie without
spoiling anything you sort of see a
little bit the literal Origins for
singing the rain as the as a movie so
you kind of see you know it's a weird
sort of indirect making of sort of
origin story for singing the rain
um because you're seeing the real things
or let's say kind of a fictional version
of the real things that ultimately
inspired seeing in the rain and where
that song came from and where the
characters came from and who they were
sort of spoofing and who they were
drawing from
um of course again Singing in the Rain
gives you a very um you know sort of of
family-friendly happy ending kind of
version of it Babylon gives you
something very different
um but uh but I think it was important
to sort of acknowledge sing in the rain
and have that dialogue
um between the two films I love that you
add it in there and Brad in that scene
is so iconic it's so funny I was talking
to Brad and Diego about how they met
because that was a really cool way you
know he was obviously a PA on a
commercial you were doing you had to
meet in that way and just everything
with yeah which was Diego's idea he was
like I'm I just got to get on this set
how can I be on this set and I think you
know because it was like
oh I remember also because it was covid
so it was like it was a commercial I was
doing with Brad before we shot Babylon
and they would only you know you can
only be on the there was no visitors
instead so you could only be allowed
because of sort of coveted numbers and
stuff you could only be allowed if you
actually had a job on set so Diego was
like I'll be a PA I'll just go grab
people coffee and stuff it's like really
you want to yeah I mean it's so funny
because it's literally like the
character he plays in the movie I mean
it's that same experience
whatever I have to do to get on that set
I'm doing and that's what he did it's
the best it's the best chemistry test
and I was also reading that Olivia
walked through a lot of the lines and
there's basically an iPhone version of
this movie that Diego's in which I
thought is really cool for me personally
I wanted to ask you
um
you know Diego was a latinx character
and is someone who's latinx I thought I
wanted to know why you made that choice
to tell a lot of the story through that
lens because that meant a lot to me
yeah I mean I you know it's I think a
lot of what inspired me with this movie
was when I would read things that felt
like I hadn't seen them before uh in in
depictions of old Hollywood for instance
I hadn't realized to what extent those
sort of early days of Hollywood were way
more uh you know diverse than we than we
often think and and uh and in some ways
there was a kind of freedom and fluidity
uh you know culturally ethnically
linguistically gender-wise sexually to
Hollywood in those early days that that
got lost that's one of the things I
think that really did get sort of
changed and suppressed and uh uh
eliminated in many ways once Hollywood
became more of a big business a big
industry and the code came in the moral
codes came in and regulations and uh it
just became less of that sort of free
circus Town
um so this movie is about in some ways
you know that sort of transition and so
it just felt right that you would have
someone in the middle of that who again
is not someone who you've seen before or
in a movie about old Hollywood and it's
also someone who would feel like both an
outsider and an Insider you know who
would feel like he was at home and not
at home always at the same time that
sort of tension
um and he's got this dream a Diego's
character man he's got this dream this
Burning dream to be part of something
bigger to be part of Hollywood
um but the odds are stacked against him
for so many reasons
um but he happens to be at the right
place at the right time when there's
this kind of weird upheaval in the
industry that allows him for a fleeting
moment to to uh to get a foot in the
door
um and uh
yeah so it sort of you know felt like
that was the right perspective in some
ways to hinge the whole movie on and
then through his eyes we'd get to know
the sort of the more you know let's say
traditional movie star types of kind of
Hollywood of that time the people that
sort of
um uh maybe would be more recognizable
like the the sort of Brad Pitt
equivalent or the Margot Robbie
equivalent of that time to get to
discover those people Through The Eyes
of a newcomer like uh like Diego playing
a newcomer like Manny felt yeah just
felt like the right choice I know that
your great grandfather used to work for
Paramount Pictures
um in London after World War one and
your great-grandmother was a British
stage actress and your grandfather I
think his name was John was actually
also in film so I wanted to know how
making this film may be changed wow I
wanted to know making this film maybe
changed your your understanding of
um your own family history well it's
funny because I think you know growing
up I I certainly didn't feel like uh I
had any family history in film it was so
sort of long ago I mean the reality is
that my grandfather was uh as a child
was in I think two movies uh when he was
like six years old and and uh partly
because yeah his stepdad at the time
worked at London Paramount office they
were in England anyway so and that was
kind of the extent of it so I remember
sort of like you know I'd kind of uh I'd
ask him questions but I would you know
it's sort of oh what was it like I would
never really maybe because he didn't
remember that much but you know I I I I
never felt like I got much in the way of
uh of details but but it did feel like
this sort of I don't know I could just
tell there was so much more to that
Iceberg than than I was uh than than I
was seeing um of course yeah it's ironic
to now be you know sort of making this
movie at Paramount but but it's um you
know it's also one of the few Studios
left in a way that's still making movies
like this and and and
um you know has that sort of that
kinship that connection that direct line
to the origins of Hollywood and to the
earliest days that you see depicted in
this movie yeah I thought that there was
that was pretty cool
I don't know it's right this whole film
and generally you can tell is the labor
of your love you know it's it's a love
letter to movies and I love movies and I
know you love movies and I really think
it's about people who want to put their
own stamp on the world and so I wanted
to know what what stamp do you want to
leave onto the movie industry in this
big
you know I guess this big ocean that we
call the movie industry that we're all
just waves in
uh yeah I I mean we I think that's
exactly right we are just waves in this
much bigger thing and I think
um
I don't know I I guess that's what
inspires me to try to take the Long View
you know and I just I just want to make
things that stand the test of time that
sort of uh feel like they're doing
playing some small part in pushing the
art form forward and trying to sort of
um expand the definitions of maybe what
you expect from a movie you know
um so I don't know you know a lot of
it's personal also it just goes back to
movie experiences that I had growing up
or as a sort of you know budding
cinephile where I would see a movie and
go
I want to do that you know it just sort
of inspire me to try something like that
or to take that kind of a risk or that
kind of a leap movies where you feel the
fearlessness you feel the you feel the
the sort of restlessness with the limits
of the form you feel like you know the
sort of ambition to not just make
another movie but to to make something
that that you know shakes people and
rattles people and shocks people and
pushes things forward
um so I think that's that's always the
ambition
um but it is about ultimately making
something that's you know hopefully
Timeless and that you know you can kind
of come back to in 50 years 100 years
you know if we're so lucky and get
something from